immune cells are constantly circulating
through your body
they monitor certain substances on the
surfaces of cells called antigens
healthy cells have different antigens
than diseased body cells or foreign
invaders in the body
immune cells usually ignore the antigens
on healthy cells
but when immune cells come across
antigens on germs they destroy the germ
for example some activated immune cells
recognize the antigen on infected body
cells and then destroy them
other activated immune cells called
plasma cells
make molecules called antibodies
these antibodies travel through your
body and lock on only to germs that have
its specific antigen
this marks the germ for destruction